bom
ou a um final de tarde para todas e
todos
é uma satisfação estar aqui eu espero
poder contribuir com alguns elementos
pressa essa diversidade de idéias é na
verdade eu trago os desafios para pensar
juntos como humanidade eu comece com uma
pergunta ter mais e mais bens materiais
é viver bem
estamos diante de uma profunda crise de
modo de viver uma crise de civilização
que é baseada no produzir cada vez mais
consumir cada vez mais e criar muitos
descartáveis
isso tem gerado riqueza sem dúvida e uma
destruição em escala global
convivemos com luxo e lixo
esta é a verdade a nossa civilização
concentra em poucas mãos exclui a
riqueza e exclui bilhões de seres
humanos 62 apenas 62 bilionários desse
sistema em mais da queda que metade da
população mundial mas que três milhões e
meio dos seres humanos
convivemos com grande desigualdade
social e injustiça
os deslocados seus territórios por
desastres ambientais e por guerras se
contam em milhões mais de 65 neste
momento estamos nessa 65 milhões
cresce perigosamente não sei das
sociedades a intolerância eo racismo o
machismo a xenofobia
uma grande ameaça paira sobre o planeta
terra eo futuro da humanidade a mudança
climática como a interdependência entre
os sistemas ecológicos e ameaça sua
integridade ea sua capacidade da face
negativa o favor necessariamente adquire
uma dimensão planetária
vocês vêem a calota polar em poucos anos
o que está acontecendo com a
globalização nos tornamos muito
independentes do local ao mundial com 11
como humanidade precisamos enfrentar um
desafio fundamental priorizar o bem
viver em coletividade
ao invés de ter mais nice bens materiais
descartáveis
quais são os caminhos possíveis
precisamos descolonizar de ter aumento
assim nossas cabeças e nossos olhares
trata-se de desmontar para os supostos
do pensamento e da ação que viram senso
comum que invade as nossas vidas e moda
até nossos sonhos e desejos
a cultura que vivemos o modo de produzir
e consumir o tipo de gestão política na
sociedade
estamos diante de uma questão de
princípios e valores éticos que define
as apelações da humanidade com a sua
própria diversidade social e cultural e
as relações da humanidade com a natureza
isso é uma questão de ciência e técnica
já que se falou muito ciência e técnica
aqui mas é de filosofia e de valores os
princípios e valores são uma espécie de
infraestrutura tanto dos liberais e do
imaginário social como das práticas em
todas as esferas da vila
quais são os princípios e valores que
nos permite fazer guerra matar uns aos
outros discriminar os diferentes da
gente porque com toda a capacidade
científica que temos favor e que
desenvolvemos ao invés de usar de forma
sustentada
fábio destruímos 1 100.000 nos oferecem
generosamente e para as relações para
nós e para as gerações futuras
estamos deixando buracos em vez de
deixar o futuro precisamos respeitar o
ciclo da água da biodiversidade da
natureza enfim precisamos repensar o
nosso lugar como seres dotados de
consciência nesse planeta ameaçado um
grande bem mas único
afinal antes de tudo somos parte da
biosfera e com ela trocamos de aorta e
nós o nosso prato é só comparar somos
natureza viva
não estamos nem acima nem ao lado são os
parte da natureza somos sendo parte da
natureza nós somos obrigados a interagir
com ela a condição do próprio vezes a
deferência e troca de nós mesmos e na
relação com a natureza
a ética dos bens comuns parte do
princípio de redes cobri-los primeiro os
bens comuns ao comum e nos organizando
como sociedade em torno a eles o que com
isso podemos criar um novo modo de ser e
de viver tanto na relação entre nós
mesmos como na relação com a natureza
mas que são comum
nós temos bens comuns naturais
recebemos como dão da natureza e são
fundamentais para todo mundo
a água a chuvas à fifa as nascentes
córregos rios mares o sol os ventos o
clima os féria como toda a
biodiversidade com todas as plantas os
solos e sua fertilidade os minerais
aberta às belezas naturais e fim
alguns são finitos como os minerais
entre eles o carvão o petróleo eo gás
que estamos simplesmente quem mandou me
manter em mente mann
outros são um estoque dado e constante
com água mas dependem do seu ciclo pode
se tornar escassos pelo uso predatório e
por no entanto temos os comuns
renováveis até muito instáveis com uma
biodiversidade nos defendendo seu uso
podem acabar
existem bebês na natureza o únicos
indivíduos como as belezas naturais e os
grandes ecossistemas que regula o clima
do planeta florestas tropicais stecz
pólos cordilheira geladas oceanos os
comuns naturais eles estão comigo feliz
nesse mapa uma parte do mapa mundo estão
distribuídas no planeta de modo
extremamente diverso com os feridos e
com partir entre a humanidade inteira
não só entra quem está num determinado
lugar
esses recursos
temos os bens comuns produzidos
isso é devido à genialidade humana que
gerou ao longo do tempo bens comuns de
grande diversidade mas de fundamental
importância para a vida e as diferentes
culturas
as línguas diferentes modos de dizer
obrigado mas as religiões as filosofias
às artes e à educação à informação e à
comunicação a ciência ea técnica à
cultura digital e os passos da política
ea própria identidade social do sul
tanto dos povos
temos os bens que combinam base na feira
material de promoção humana as cidades
os territórios de cidadania às ruas
estradas as praças dos lugares sagrados
e igrejas cemitérios enfim os espaços
públicos que todos compartilhamos entre
nós
os bens comuns produzidos são
teoricamente ilimitados
quanto mais se combate mais cresce
meu conhecimento ele só cresce no
compartilhar
língua só cresce no compartilhando é a
única maneira de fazer as línguas e
falando na sua fronteira da expansão do
bem viver e da felicidade humana só
acontece com a cultura ciência técnica
qual é o caráter do beijupirá comum os
bebês não nascem não são comuns são
socialmente tornados como comum é uma
qualidade intrínseca ao bem mas é uma
qualidade que a relação social atribui
as garrafas são sementes e o outro é uma
luta de estelita e pernambuco contra
imobiliárias que queriam transformar
esse lugar e em um centro deve se em um
lugar privado os comuns mais do que
benson aquilo que as relações sociais
identifiquem geram como tais
a necessidade sentida almejado
enfrentada politicamente leva a criar
bem comum
um exemplo bem como resgatar a general
bens comuns é criar as condições de
outro modo de vida
o caráter de comuns pois se constituindo
ao longo do tempo de parar para com a
gestão coletiva ser parte de um grupo
uma comunidade um povo e para os bens da
humanidade ter o direito de compartilhar
tais bens comuns é aquele de citar a
atmosfera é um bem comum natural está
sendo privatizada pela poluição de
alguns mais que de outros de algumas
sociedades e sobretudo de algumas da luz
modos de usar e está sendo colonizado
nesse sentido e destruída com o brinco
nem privado nem estatal
simplesmente comuns os pulmões como uma
espécie de substrato comum da vida em
sociedade serve a todas e todos os
comuns são a rede da vida natural social
cultural e digital rolarem comuns de se
referir à qualidade da água
vida e do futuro as ameaças
um exemplo ver só
privatiza praia praia é um bem comum de
todos
o encurtamento a privatização e
mercantilização que acontece com muitos
bem é maior ameaça é tornar escasso
antona tarô com finalidade comercial só
fazer isso mas também a poluição
atmosférica no clássico que nós julgamos
a poluição que da nata da vida marinha à
destruição da biodiversidade o nosso
caso aqui uma das maiores ameaças ao
desmatamento e à propriedade intelectual
ea mercantilização da ciência e da
cultura princípios e valores éticos para
conservar e ampliar os comuns
o cuidado atividade essencial do ser
humano no cotidiano é o princípio fundo
dos bens comuns sem o cuidado as
condições de vida própria vida não
existe o cuidado ao princípio
indispensável do viver em comunidade
seja família o grupo mais enviado como o
círculo de amigos e às vezes de que
participamos o território em que vivemos
pequeno grande
enfim a onde estamos o bem comum
nasci floresce com o cuidado juntos
protegendo como o caso na praia como
direito e responsabilidade de todos e
todos a nossa água o nosso território
com seus recursos belezas a nossa
identidade coletiva os nossos filhos e
filhas nossos idosos e idosas nossas
festas nossas celebrações de lojas nossa
cidade nossa praia nossa água nossa
montanha conviver e compartilhar com
todos são os princípios e valores éticos
essenciais para manter os comuns no
centro das nossas vidas
os princípios do cuidado da convivência
por favor
e do compartilhamento de tudo o que é
tornado e gerido como comum são os
pilares de um novo modo de ver do bem
viver
isso é uma luta e contra a vale ao norte
da cidade de belo horizonte proteger
nascentes de água ea montanha que a vale
quer transformar cada um buraco no menu
bem viver e eu termino aqui é priorizar
os comuns héteros no centro e participar
é compartilhada é conviver é cuidar é
ser titular do direito de ter os mesmos
direitos iguais aos dos outros é ser e
viver como cidadania que compartilha o
planeta terra
outro mundo é possível obrigado
[Aplausos]